from a low budget show on true tv to a
globe circling phenomenon impractical
jokers is this century's little comedy
show that could
compulsively watchable and impossible to
watch at the same time
the good natured cringe comedy stars
lifelong pals
joe gatto james murr murray brian q
quinn and sal volcano who grew up
performing comedy together in staten
island new york
together the four produce and act out
some of the best grown male buffoonery
you can find on television today
i run a project where i bring pictures
of all different girls in bikinis to
prisoners in exchange for woodworkings
from their original intentions for the
show to the most angry mark they ever
pranked
here's the facts you didn't know about
impractical jokers
let the ceremony begin
jokers the next generation you know what
impractical jokers doesn't have
a really pram and proper narrator but in
their original pitch they wanted one
and had the perfect guy in mind when we
first created the show
we wanted the narrator to be um
patrick stewart and we wanted him to
hate us
[Music]
as fans were aware it didn't work out
but it was a pretty inspired idea
in the joker's minds stuart would spend
the episodes hating the show
openly disparaging the jokers as they
went about their pranks
he would like he'd introduce every
challenge and say these are at it again
to stewart's credit he's already had
more than enough of a guy named q
murr's cringe-worthy debut on paper
james mer murray is the most
professionally put together of the
impractical jokers
with his position as a seasoned producer
and an ample amount of showbiz savvy
of course even talented people have to
work up to their biggest successes and
what comes before the success can be
really rough murr got a harsh reminder
of his indie film roots with a challenge
involving his disastrous first feature
film
damned which he wrote produced and
directed in 1998.
as part of a punishment in the episode
damned if you do
mer was forced to watch a packed
screening of his first movie
suffering through an embarrassing q a
session in front of the audience after
it wrapped up
possibly the budget was very tight uh
the budget was
uh about uh 25 30 000 dollars
following the misadventures of a modern
day teenage jesus
murr's expensive debut is embarrassing
the most incredible thing about the
movie is that it cost thirty thousand
dollars to make
from the look of the finished product
it's like only fifty dollars ended up on
screen
but wilson wells was in his twenties
when he made citizen kane
uh what's your excuse after the episode
true tv uploaded the entire 52-minute
movie to its website for free streaming
kicked off with a new intro from murr so
if you want to see the story of the
bible
but with a lot more butt rock on the
soundtrack you
and only you should definitely check it
out
shut down at the ball game much of
impractical joker's tension lies in
people's reactions to the pranks
and waiting to see whether they're going
to play along or throw a punch
i'm watching the guy right now i'll be
on the lookout
turns out seeing someone absolutely lose
it on the jokers is
actually extremely uncomfortable
according to joe
the angriest person the production ever
encountered took place at city field
the prank a punishment for joe involved
stealing baseballs autographed by mets
pitcher noah cindergaard from the
funniest possible victims
little kids the sight of joe casually
robbing young baseball fans of their
souvenirs
is one of those atrocious ideas that the
series is so good at but things went off
the rails when one mark went full mama
bear on him
you cannot do that give me the ball
that's wrong
this one according to joe and executive
producer pete mcpartland
the mother was so furious that the whole
production was derailed
no never ever in a million years has
anyone been that upset at anyone on
impractical
jokers that is until this happened
what's that no you know what it is
okay even after the situation was
explained
the anonymous giant gentleman waited
outside for murr to appear so he could
finish the job
and he wouldn't allow his face to be on
television
sexist or racist cringe comedy is baked
into in practical joker's dna
but it can still make the show torture
to watch the jokers
never look worse than the times they're
forced to personally antagonize people
based on their gender or race
the michelle obama thing she got there
because she
slept with a man in one ask the joker's
after show
joe was asked by a viewer whether it's
more difficult to pretend to be sexist
or racist i'm trying to think of the
right
answer here because either way feels
like a trap
after a couple of minutes of thinking
about it joe came to the conclusion
it's probably harder to pretend to be
sexist it's not too surprising of an
answer
these jokers are italian boys from
staten island after all
of course they defend the honor of their
mothers and sisters first
hey mom what are you doing i'm at work i
hate
you [ __ ]
background focus one accusation that's
dugged in practical jokers over the
years
is the same one that gets lobbed at
every reality show
this is fake for the most part these
accusations are off base
but sometimes viewers can raise real
questions especially
when they spot the same extras
participating in completely different
episodes
fortunately you don't have to be too
skeptical about the show
q addressed the issue head on in 2018
saying
we don't use actors we use the people
who go to focus groups a lot and
sometimes the same person shows up
but they never realize they're on the
show for some reason
can i tell you where i think i know you
from yes but not right now
because what you think you know me from
is happening oh the last resort
in practical joker's sole mission is to
be weird in public and get the funniest
footage
possible once the production gets that
footage they'll go to just about
any length to make sure they can use it
in order to show interactions in their
unobscured glory the production has to
get signed releases from every mark they
want to use on screen
which can be pretty tricky after they
spent five straight minutes making
someone angry on purpose
asked on reddit if the production ever
hands out money to people they're
pranking
sal said usually people are pretty cool
when they find out it's a show
the few who get mad we try to convince
otherwise
or they get blurred or cut from the show
on rare occasions if the person was gold
we try and throw them a few bucks to
coerce them our advice
keep that in the back of your mind just
in case the joker has ever happened to
pull a prank on you
no matter how you really feel about it
your best move is to get mad
stay mad and get paid gotta do it
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too